we discuss what we know about the
YouTube shooting Robert Muller announces
that President Trump is not a criminal
target and president Trump says he's
gonna put the military on the border
we'll discuss all of it I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
all right so we do have a lot to get to
today we're going to go through in
Folsom detail everything that we know
about the YouTube shooter about the
attempted murderer over at YouTube who
shot herself after wounding several
people we're not going to mention her
name because that's something that we
don't do here on the bench Shapiro show
we also don't do it a Daily wire and
that's an edict that I put down after
the Parkland shooting where we do not
cover the actual name of the shooter so
if you want the name of this year you'll
have to go elsewhere I don't think it's
that important we'll give you all the
information you need to know about her
without actually naming her and
glorifying her in the way that the media
are doing we know from studies that it
is important of not to mention the names
of shooters if you want to stop copycat
crimes we'll discuss all of those things
in just a second first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at legacy
box so here's the deal right now
in your garage you have a bunch of old
films old pictures or cassette tapes you
have all this stuff and it's just
moldering away it's it's degrading over
time it's gonna be unplayable unusable
it's gonna get waterlogged there'll be
bugs that get in it well instead of just
letting that stuff to grade in your
garage instead what you should do is go
to my friends over at legacy box and let
them help you out the way this works you
take all of those tapes you take all
those pictures everything you throw it
in a box and you send it to legacy box
ok legacy box sends you a box you take
all of these things the old films the
tapes the pictures the audio recordings
you send it back and then in a couple of
weeks all of it comes back to you
original materials plus a DVD or thumb
drive with all of this stuff on it
so you can relive rewatch enjoy it all
the time I've done this for my parents
it is a fantastic gift for your parents
it's a fantastic it for yourself if
you're trying to maintain your childhood
memories without those things withering
away there's a reason over 350,000
families have used legacy box and for a
limited time when you go to legacy box
comm slash Ben you get a 40% discount on
your order that's legacy box comm slash
been for that 40% discount again legacy
box comm slash been use that slash Ben
so we know so they know that we sent you
again fantastic service nothing more
important in life than preserving those
memories you've created if you let them
mold or away it's gonna be your own
fault so go to legacy box comm slash Ben
and get that 40 percent discount on your
order alright so yesterday in the middle
of the day a woman walked into the
YouTube headquarters in Northern
California and began shooting up the
place we are not going to mention her
name as I say because here at the Daily
wire and on my podcast in particular
I have a policy my policy is that we
don't mention the names of attempted
mass shooters because studies tend to
show that when you glorify mass shooters
all that does is create copycats people
want to think that their message is
getting out there so what we will
discuss is everything we know about this
woman what about actually mentioning her
specific name just what you need to know
as news consumers so according to
Mercury News in San Jose the night
before this woman opened fire in a
courtyard at YouTube's headquarters
Tuesday afternoon Mountain View police
found this woman sleeping in her car
she'd been reported missing by her
family in Southern California and her
father told police she might be going to
YouTube because she hated the company
okay so we here's what we know already
she's crazy
she hates YouTube hey she put up a bunch
of videos on YouTube about being
demonetised and she's an animal rights
protesters within Islamic background her
dad is Muslim I guess all I can say is
that her videos make it fairly clear
that she is not a an orthodox observant
Muslim she's dressed in garb that I
don't think traditional Muslims would be
particularly happy with are there bunch
of videos of her doing exercise videos
and she was demonetised she had about
fifty five thousand followers on
Instagram I guess is the is the latest
she had a few followers on YouTube and
YouTube cracked down on some of her
videos and she was very angry at YouTube
for that and so her dad called the cops
and said she might be going to YouTube
the cops obviously did nothing so just
like in parkland the cops are told over
and over and over there was no follow up
and this person obviously was unwell
okay I'm not going to sit here and
diagnose this person with anything but a
person who creates these kind of videos
there's some there's a screw loose okay
just in conventional terminology this
woman had a screw loose after this guy
the father called the police the police
called the family at 2 a.m. Tuesday to
say that this woman had been found that
everything was under control but hours
later this woman was dead of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound after
shooting three people and causing an
afternoon of Terror at youtube's
headquarters in an interview Tuesday
night with the Bay Area News Group this
woman's father said his 38 year old
daughter told her family a couple of
weeks ago the YouTube had been censoring
her videos and stopped paying her for
her content she was angry he said in an
interview it wasn't clear Tuesday night
what Mountain View police knew about her
history with YouTube a police
spokeswoman confirmed that officers had
found a woman of the same name asleep in
a vehicle early Tuesday morning in a
parking lot and the officers made
contact with the woman
the license plate of her vehicle matched
that of a missing person out of SoCal
the woman confirmed her identity and
answered subsequent questions at the
conclusion of their discussion her
family was notified that she had been
located so according to her dad his
daughter was a vegan activist and animal
lover as a youngster she would not even
kill ants that invaded the family home
instead using paper to remove them to
the backyard state records show she had
once established a charity called peace
thunder Inc which sounds fantastic to
educate people about animal cruelty
environmental pollution and other causes
says she's a left-wing activist within
Islamic background and choose a vegan
and she made weird youtube videos and
these videos are really weird and again
I'm not gonna show you the YouTube
videos because I don't think the future
channeling future shooters should have
it in their mind that the media are
going to give them the sort of coverage
they seek if they go and shoot people so
according to this woman she was actually
quoted by the San Diego union-tribune at
a PETA rally in 2009 outside Camp
Pendleton the People for the Ethical
Treatment of Animals and she said for me
animal rights equal human rights she
told her family that YouTube had stopped
paying her for the content she posted to
the site youtubers of course can receive
payments if their videos have been
monetized she was prolific on social
media she posted videos and photos on
Instagram Facebook YouTube it's very
weird
there's strange war cat video clips
graphic animal abuse videos and vegan
cooking tutorials but a bunch of her
latest posts show evidence of her
growing frustration apparently all of
her pages were taken down late on
Tuesday but for example in a March 18th
the Instagram post she railed at YouTube
quote all my YouTube channels got
filtered by YouTube so my videos hardly
get views and it is called merely
relegation this also happened to many
other channels on YouTube this is the
peaceful tactic used on the internet
censor and suppress people who speak the
truth and are not good for the financial
political gains of the system and big
businesses I recently got filter on
Instagram too and maybe it's related to
YouTube and YouTube staff asked to
Instagram to filter me here - and then
she recorded a video on january 28th
where she was complaining about her
perceived discrimination by YouTube she
said I'm being discriminated and
filtered on YouTube but I'm not the only
one they restricted my ab workout video
Aviva has nothing bad in it nothing
sexual
she has at least four YouTube channels
one in English and then others in Farsi
and Turkish as well so the original
story that was coming out of the police
department is that this was a woman who
was angry an ex-boyfriend and so she
went into YouTube and started shooting
up
place it is now clear or at least
becoming clear that there's not a lot of
evidence for this that it seems more
likely that she had a vendetta against
YouTube and she decided to just go and
start shooting the family apparently
came to california from iran in 1996 and
apparently this woman was living with
her grandmother and she was always
complaining that youtube ruined her life
so apparently she nobody knows where she
got the gun it was not a rifle i believe
i believe that this was a handgun and
that's what we know about this this
woman she would have turned 40 in two
days and again she is she had problems
it's very clear there's a woman who was
mentally ill right and she she said in
one video quote they want you to be
their sex slaves and not think outside
the box they designed for you your
knowledge is their enemy this is what
she said about youtube her family said
she's been making a living as a youtube
personality so here's here's what comes
out of this first of all the entire left
as soon as the shooting went down said
okay this obviously means we must have
gun control because when you're a hammer
everything looks like a nail
every single thing looks like a nail and
in this particular case the hammer
doesn't fit the nail because it's pretty
obvious that this woman had serious
problems it's not clear where she got
the gun yet we don't know the answer
depriving me of a gun would not have
deprived this woman of a gun at least we
don't know that a blank a gun
confiscation would have done that this
doesn't appear to have been an AR and so
this isn't gonna be top-line news for
the media for much longer than 24 hours
it would have been top-line news if this
had been an NRA activist it would've
been top-line news if this had been a
devotee of the ben shapiro show but
since this person is a weird person with
mental illness and left-wing leanings
and a Muslim background that means this
is not going to be news beyond you know
the next five minutes then the media is
gonna bury this one we'll get right back
to Parkland which has a nice narrative
the media can Guam on to ignoring of
course all the facts about what happened
in parkland were the FBI ignored
warnings in the local police ignored
warnings and then the shooting happened
anyway so look for this shooting to hit
the back pages in about five seconds
flat again because it doesn't promote
the agenda that folks wanted to promote
the entire Left decided that they were
going to jump immediately on this as it
was happening and this is one of the
problems with social media places like
Facebook and in YouTube and Twitter is
that people react immediately to all of
this stuff as soon as it happens right
as soon as it happens people are
acting without reference to reality so
Michael Ian Black is already tweeting he
wants to take away all the guns the
comedian is tweeting that he wants to
take away everybody's guns he's coming
for our guns why do we even have the
fact to know we don't have the facts but
the narrative must be pervade at all
costs and then folks on the right are
saying well maybe this woman was a
religious Muslim maybe it's a terrorist
attack based on the initial report that
it was a woman in the headscarf who
walked in so nobody actually waits for
the facts to come out it's important to
wait for the facts to come out because
if you don't wait for the facts to come
out you screw things up and in this
particular case the facts demonstrate
that once again we had a mentally ill
person who was basically being ignored
by the cops and the cops ins what
they're supposed to every red flag was
there she was she was the police were
told that she had a vendetta against
YouTube now the other thing that you may
see in the coming days is the media
tried to turn this into a defense of
YouTube's policies suggesting for
example that this woman was was egged on
by people who were angry at YouTube and
angry at social media that she was
angered because there are so many people
on the right particularly who talked
about the problems with D monetization
of video now in order to get to that
point they would have to ignore the fact
that this woman was in fact left-wing
and she's rallying with people for the
Ethical Treatment of Animals but that
wouldn't stop the left before the
reality is that every time there is a
shooting the left immediately swivels
and tries to blame it on the right this
goes all the way back to the JFK
assassination when the New York Times
attempted to blame right-wingers for the
JFK assassination even though JFK was
assassinated by a communist who may have
may or may not have been in contact with
the Cuban government they tried to blame
it on the right they suggested it was
America's collective guilt you may see
that emerge in the aftermath of the
shooting but now you know what you need
to know about the shooter and again it's
pretty clear this does not fit into the
narrative that the left would like from
all of this now what would have stopped
something like this presumably a gun
violence restraining order if she
obtained her weapon legally so some of
the stuff that Marco Rubio is pushing
and some of the stuff that's been pushed
by David French over at National Review
the policy that suggests that family and
friends could have gone to a judge and
said this woman should not have guns
because she's a danger to herself or
others that would have stopped her from
getting a gun what else would have
helped well if the police had followed
up and ensured that this woman did not
have guns after it turns out that she
was sleeping in her car and ran Singh
about YouTube one of the big problems
that we have in American society with
regard to the treatment of mental
is we act as though a person who rants
crazy things and lives in their car is
just exercising normal American freedoms
hey you don't have the freedom to sleep
in your car in public areas and you
don't have the freedom to be deeply
mentally ill in danger to yourself or
others and the ACLU has made a cause a
crusade out of ensuring that for example
homeless people get to sleep on the
streets in Los Angeles it's not this
person was not homeless presumably she
was living with her parents but she
clearly had some problems and when there
are problems like this again Jared
Lochner the shooter in in in the Gabby
Giffords situation the shooter in Aurora
Colorado the shooter in in in Sandy Hook
the shooter in parkland and all of these
people had serious mental health issues
serious mental health problems Virginia
Tech and there were warning signs and
people didn't do what they were supposed
to do in just a second I'm gonna get to
the other big story of the day and that
of course is regarding President Trump
and whether he is a target of criminal
investigation Robert Romo comes up with
some some interesting analysis but first
I want to say thank you to our sponsors
over a policy genius so 71% of people
say they need life insurance but only
59% two people have coverage so that's a
pretty solid discrepancy a lot of people
who say they want life insurance haven't
bothered to go get the coverage so 12
percents of people are just
procrastinating they're just sitting
around they're not doing what they're
supposed to do and while you're
procrastinating policy genius was making
life insurance easier so now is the time
for you to go get your life insurance
okay just do it now before you die
because once you die it's too late to do
it and then your family's screwed so you
need policy genius it's the easy way to
compare life insurance online you can
compare quotes in just five minutes when
it's that easy putting it off becomes a
lot harder so you can compare those
quotes you can sit on the couch watch TV
you can compare quotes while listening
to this podcast policy genius has helped
over 4 million people shop for insurance
and placed over 20 billion dollars in
coverage and they don't treat just you
life insurance disability insurance
renter's insurance health insurance if
your care enough about it and if you
care enough about something to insure it
policy genius probably has a program for
you so right now go over to policy
genius.com that's policy genius calm the
easy way to compare top insurers and
find the best value for your no sales
pressure zero hassle when you compare
prices you save money policy genius calm
when it's this easy why not just do it
right now go over there head over there
policy genius calm okay
so meanwhile the other big news of the
day yesterday is that Robert Mueller
Muller I'm still confused as to how
we're actually supposed to pronounce his
name so for the sake of argument we will
say Muller right now
but Robert Muller who is the special
investigator who was tasked by the DOJ
with checking in to supposed Trump
Russia collusion in the last election
cycle he has now come out with some
information and suggested that President
Trump is not in fact a target of the
investigation when the the rest of the
laughs the entire left is is now doing
Bill Paxton from aliens game over man
game over they they just they can't
believe that Robert Muller isn't gonna
come in deus ex machina announced
President Trump from office with some
sort of criminal indictment here's what
the Washington Post reported that blew
up the internet last night special
counsel Robert a smaller the third
informed president Trump's attorneys
last month that he is continuing to
investigate the president but does not
consider him a criminal target at this
point according to three people familiar
with the discussions in private
negotiations in early March about a
possible presidential interview Muller
described from as a subject of his
investigation into Russia's interference
in the 2016 election
prosecutors view someone as a subject
from that person has engaged in contact
that is under investigation
but there is not sufficient evidence to
bring charges the special counsel also
told Trump's lawyer that he's preparing
a report about the president's actions
while in office and potential
obstruction of justice according to two
people with knowledge of the
conversations mala reiterated the need
to interview Trump both to understand
whether he had any corrupt intent to
thwart the Russian investigation and to
complete this portion of his probe the
people said no if description of the
President status has sparked friction
within Trump's inner circle as his
advisers have debated his legal standing
so the president some of his allies they
apparently are seizing on Mullins words
as an insurance that Trump it's risk of
criminal jeopardy is low but other
advisers say well subject can quickly
become an indicted target so there are a
couple of questions here and some good
news for Trump and some bad news for
Trump in this report from the Washington
Post about what Robert Muller is
labeling Trump a target a subject but
not a target of the investigation so
point number one after a year of
investigation more than a year an
investigation by the DOJ and about nine
months of investigation by team Muller
there is no evidence to indict Trump at
this point but there isn't so all of the
talk about how Trump is on the ropes and
Trump is is going to be ousted from
office in a criminal
station there is not evidence at this
point which means that the only evidence
that Muller can get is from Trump
himself and this brings us right here
this brings us to some of the bad news
for president Trump when Muller says
that President Trump is a target of the
a subject but not a target of the
investigation what he means is that he's
still looking at everything Trump is
doing but he doesn't have enough
information to indict that could change
and so what he could be doing here is
making Trump feel comfortable he could
be saying to him you know mr. president
look I don't have the evidence to indict
you right now I have no interest really
in inciting you but I need to talk with
you to clarify Trump would be a fool to
get in a room with Robert Muller and
testify under oath he would be or even
to talk to the FBI generally because
it's still a crime to lie to the FBI
even if you're not under oath the reason
is this let's say that right now one of
the things we know is that Muller is
doing two things one is the possible
criminal investigation against Trump for
obstruction of justice now is that
discussed on the program before the case
for obstruction against President Trump
is particularly weak it's very difficult
for the President of the United States
to obstruct justice when he is just
firing members of the executive branch
the president has tremendous control
over the executive branch and firing
anybody inside the executive branch it's
difficult to claim that there would
actually be a a solid case against
President Trump so I've done this before
but I'm gonna do it again let me explain
to you what obstruction of justice
constitutes under federal law so under
18 US Code 1503 is called the Omnibus
clause okay it covers corruptly or by
any threatening letter or communication
influencing or impeding or endeavoring
to influence obstruct or impede the due
administration of justice but the clause
requires a pending judicial proceeding
there is no pending judicial proceeding
right now if there were a pending
judicial proceeding if for example Trump
fired James Comey in order protects
Michael Flynn then that would be one
thing but if you fired James Comey just
because he got mad or if he fired James
Comey because he didn't want James Comey
investigating him then that would all be
actually perfectly legal under this
clause it's only if there's a pending
judicial proceeding and the president
interferes with that pending judicial
proceeding by firing someone maybe that
you could theoretically say that's
obstruction very difficult to make that
case when the president obviously has
the right to fire someone like James
Comey the former FBI director who was
underneath his rule right under his per
in the executive branch okay another
clause of federal law that's often used
when you're talking about obstruction is
18 US Code 1512 see this provision of
law covers anyone who quote obstructs
influences or impedes an official
proceeding or attempts to do so so it's
not clear that an FBI investigation is
an official proceeding and more than
that you have to prove intense you have
to prove that President Trump actually
intended to obstruct the investigation
he wasn't just pissed at James Comey I
think realistically speaking that's
exactly why he fired James Comey the
former FBI director he was angry at him
because he went to kill me he said why
don't you just say I'm not under
investigation and Comey said I don't
want to say that and Trump said but I'm
not am i and cuming said right you're
not under investigation from said well
why don't you say that
and Comey said I don't want it when
Trump fired him I mean I think I really
I think that's how things went down
final piece of the u.s. code that deals
with obstruction of justice provision
this provision covers destroying
evidence related to a federal
investigation is 18 US Code 15-19 there
are no accusations at this point that
Trump has destroyed evidence of any kind
so again very difficult to make a
criminal case an obstruction of justice
against the President of the United
States however even if Trump talks to
Muller and then he says something like
yeah I fired him because I didn't like
what he was doing with Flynt boom now
you're talking about a possible
obstruction of justice charge
okay would be difficult to prove in
court it would be really out of the box
for the President of the United States
to be actually charged with obstruction
obstruction of justice obstruction of
justice was part of the the impeachment
proceeding however against Richard Nixon
and this brings us to the second point
with regard to what Muller is doing so
what Muller is doing here right is he is
compiling a report to issue to Congress
that seems to me perfectly appropriate
considering that this is basically a
political issue but I'm not sure that it
was inside Mulder's purview in the first
place now Alan Dershowitz who's a
defense lawyer obviously a Harvard Law
School professor he has suggested that
Muller is operating outside his purview
his purview is not to issue reports to
Congress his purview is not to issue
intelligence or counterintelligence
reports his issue is to do a criminal
investigation either he's got the goods
or he doesn't
if he doesn't have the goods then he
should shut up that's that's tertian
what's his basic point here is that
every Special Counsel investigation is
set has set parameters and Muller has
exceeded those parameters other people
who believe this Andy McCarthy over a
national view has made the same case
that Muller's parameters have expanded
and expand
and expanded so now we're no longer
talking about Trump Russia collusion
anywhere in here right Trump Russia
collusion has nothing to do with
anything instead we are now talking
about something completely different
possible obstruction of justice by
President Trump but this is a problem
for President Trump because remember
there's an election coming up in 2018
and in just a second I'm gonna explain
to you why Muller's little report to
Congress could be pretty devastating for
President Trump just another reason why
Trump probably should not talk to them
all I'll explain that in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blinds.com so
blinds.com
is the the place that you need to go if
you are interested in ensuring that your
house doesn't look like a trash heap
okay one of the things that you never
look at one of the things that you never
pay attention to is the blinds on your
windows they just don't they look like
garbage they look terrible but the
reality is that you need to pay
attention to those blinds because the
window coverings in your house actually
make a pretty large difference we just
had some of our blinds replaced by
blinds calm and everything looks a lot
better and blends that comix it really
easy freezy don't have to go to a store
you don't have to shop around if someone
come to your house instead you go to
blinds calm and if you're not sure what
you want or even where to start with
blinds.com you get a free online design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
furniture and specific rooms they'll
even send you free samples to make sure
everything looks as good in person as it
does online every single order gets free
shipping and here's the best part you
screw it up it's your fault you must
measure you pick the wrong color if you
screw it up
blinds calm remakes your blinds for free
they've made it really easy for you for
a limited time you get right now 20% off
everything at blinds calm when you use
promo code Ben so make sure you use
promo code Ben to get 20% off everything
at blinds.com we're talking for what
blinds cellular shades roller shades and
more blinds calm promo code Ben rules
and restrictions do apply blinds.com
promo code Ben make your house look
fantastic blind STATCOM promo code Ben
and again when you use promo code Ben
you let them know that we sent you an
you get 20% off all of the things so
that's pretty awesome deal check it out
blinds calm promo code Ben ok so back to
the Muller investigation so as we say
according to the Washington Post Muller
is drafting a large report that he's
going to issue to Congress and this of
course will be a bombshell
no matter what it says if Muller says
you know Trump acted improperly but it's
not Krim
then if Democrats went back Congress
they will attempt to impeach him so here
is why 2018 matters for Republicans if
they don't want to see Trump impeached
in the house now the chances that he's
impeached in the Senate are virtually no
but he could be or convicted in the
Senate anyway he could be impeached in
the house if Democrats went back to
Congress and right now the polls suggest
that they are very likely to win back
Congress which means let's say mutlar
issues this report a few months down the
road let's say issues it in December
let's say issues in September and this
becomes an issue if he issues it before
the election Democrats will use this as
elect us and we will impeach Trump right
hope will spring alive and anew for
Democrats and the turnout will be even
greater than it otherwise would be
because they will now have the grounds
to go after President Trump if he does
it after the election and Democrats run
the house then there will presumably be
some sort of impeachment proceeding
because all they need is the drop of a
hat and they're gonna move to impeach
Trump just because they don't like Trump
doesn't matter and we've been hearing
nothing about collusion doesn't matter
the collusion was the buzzword for
literally a year and a half here none of
that matters they'll talk about
obstruction obstruction sure there was
no collusion but there was obstruction
and the president was acting in criminal
fashion and that means we have to
impeach him so this is why Trump should
not talk to Muller because if he talks
to Muller is there any doubt that if
you're Trump's lawyer you're just
gritting your teeth the entire time if
your Trump's lawyer President Trump has
an unfortunate habit of making loud
brash statements you can't do that in
front of lawyers you do that in front of
Muller and Muller will catch you in a
perjury trap faster than you can say boo
so there you actually do have criminal
liability right there you actually have
a problem if Trump actually lies to the
FBI then you have a crime but even if he
doesn't lie to the FBI if he provides
any evidence that that allows Muller to
suggest obstruction that's not quite
criminal but it's uncomfortable and
weird then you could see Democrats move
to impeach President Trump and that of
course is the end goal of so many of
these folks yeah this investigation is
still dangerous now does that mean that
Trump should fire Muller no because then
there'd presumably be an impeachment
proceeding against Trump by the house
anyway for obstruction but at least we
can fight back if the Muller report
proves to be particularly weak everybody
is jumping to conclusions suggesting
that Trump is off the hook now that's
not right everybody who's suggesting
that this shows that Trump is on the
hook
that's not right either we don't have
enough information Trump
to be protecting himself and if Trump
believes that this is going to let him
off the hook that it's gonna that
everything's gonna be fine
this is now in the political court okay
this is no longer in the legal Court it
probably won't be in a legal court it
will be in the political court and that
could be a serious problem for president
Trump although I will say this if the
Democrats try to impeach Trump in 2018
and he doesn't get convicted in the
Senate and he remains in office
how big is turnout gonna be for
Republicans in 2020 and nothing was
better for Bill Clinton than republicans
attempting to impeach him in 1998 his
approval ratings skyrocketed is 60% so I
think the same thing will happen with
Trump notes I think Trump is a more
polarizing figure on the American public
scene or at least people react to him in
a more polarized way but if Democrats
try to impeach him on weak grounds that
would be a political mistake that could
really hurt them in the in the reelect
effort into in 2020 okay so meanwhile
the President of the United States
President Trump has now decided that he
wants to put the military on our
southern border and Democrats are losing
their minds here as president Trump
announcing that he wants to put the
military on the border yesterday Louis
for a border and we are going to be
doing some things I've been speaking
with general mattis we're going to be
doing things military later until we can
have a wall in proper security we're
gonna be guarding our border with the
military okay so the left went nuts over
this so he says listen we don't have
proper security we should be guarding
our border with the military he says
we'll use the National Guard for all of
us I think this is a fine move I have no
problem whatsoever what the president
putting the National Guard on the border
this is what he was elected to do he was
elected to solidify that border and it's
amazing to me that so many members and
left are truly upset about all of this
what do they think ice is ice is a
federal armed force that is on the
border this is just supplementing that
federal armed force with members of the
National Guard and right now there is a
serious problem with not just illegal
immigration but flow of drugs and crime
across that southern border even the
Mexican ambassador came out yesterday
and said that they they understand
president Trump's concerns that you know
this isn't completely ridiculous
important we certainly understand the
concern not only that President Trump
has but people in the United States here
have about immigration okay so even the
Mexican ambassador I think is making
some noises that are that are correct
here the Mexican government has
facilitated illegal immigration this is
true
seeking government benefits from
remittances from from people who cross
the border illegally into America and
then send money back to their family
back in Mexico they have an interest in
the sort of cross-border monetary
transfers that have been happening into
Mexico and that's why Mexico is not anti
illegal immigration even though there
are anti illegal immigration into Mexico
but there's a deeper question at issue
here first of all I just want to point
this out the reality is that illegal
immigration does carry with it serious
risks not just in terms of crime but
also in terms of the heroin epidemic
there's a great book called dreamland by
San Wynonna's I've recommended it on the
show before and the things that I like
and one of the things that one of the
things that the book talks about is the
fact that the heroin epidemic that's
been taking place has largely been
pushed by black tar heroin traffickers
out of a small town called Alisa Co in
the state of Nayarit in Mexico who they
take drugs they take drugs they look for
new markets and they've set up an entire
distribution system all throughout the
United States so according to Quinn
ona's Mexican drug cartels use customer
service they deliver just like pizza
delivery and it really appeals to this
new class of addicts who are white
really kind of unfamiliar maybe a lot of
times with the drug world they don't
want to get involved in Skid Row or
housing projects where everyone has
always bought dope a drug addict wants
one thing above all and that's
reliability and these guys provided that
above all they relied on being very
low-profile they didn't spend their
money lavishly they look like the day
workers outside your Home Depot they
drove old cars they never used gunplay
drive-by shootings or any of that kind
of stuff because they didn't need to
according to Quinn ona's all these guys
don't like selling heroin but here's the
thing back in the town where they're
from they've been humiliated all their
lives their jobs are dead-end jobs they
work as Baker's they work as farm boys
they work as butchers they don't have
anything pushing them ahead and as the
business model began to take hold in
Jalisco Mexico the effects were
immediately seen in the town people
began to do better they began to build
big houses that again to have nice
trucks nice cars all around them young
men saw this and they saw that this was
a route to real economic progress one of
the strangest things I encountered when
I was doing this book was how Levi's
501s were these huge forces in pushing
the system across the United States that
he's very well made very expensive jeans
and the system was a system for turning
cheap heroin into stacks of Levi's 501s
because dealers noticed that addicts
they were selling to or fantastic
shoplifters so I mean there's a whole
system here if the book is really
phenomenal and
really I think a must-read they talk
about the fact that this entire Mexican
drug cartel invaded the United States
and when people are about to be arrested
and deported
those people are deported back to the
United States did you send people right
across the border new people right
across the border Trump is not wrong to
use the military on the border in order
to secure that border but in a second
I'm gonna explain to you something
amazing and that is why the left is so
all-fired enamored really enamored with
the idea of keeping the border open and
I have a couple of clips to show you and
clips to talk about on that but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Chappaquiddick so as I say if
they not sponsor Chappaquiddick to be on
the program I would still be talking
about Chappaquiddick that's how good the
movie is it is a must watch you should
go see Chappaquiddick it is coming out
on April 6 so just two days from now you
can see it I've already seen in the film
the film is tremendous not only is it
well acted not only is it beautifully
shot not only is it beautifully written
but it really tells a story about one of
the worst crime covers up in the history
of the United States that is Ted Kennedy
leaving Mary Jo Kopechne in to drown in
about six feet of water she actually
died suffocating in an air bubble at the
top of the car so it wasn't that he left
her and she was already drowned she was
alive in the car when he left her and
then he went home he went to sleep he
woke up the next morning and only in the
next morning did he call the cops by
which point she had suffocated to death
in the air bubble at the top of the car
all he had to do was walk about 50 feet
to a phone make a call to the police and
Mary Jo Kopechne would be alive today
and if he had by the way Ted Kennedy
probably would be President he would
have been president but Ted Kennedy did
not do that the movie is fascinating in
so many ways not just because it paints
a really realistic picture of what
happened at Chappaquiddick but also
because it took 50 years to even got
this on the screen which is an
incredible thing again imagine the top
Republican candidate top Republican
contender you know somebody like a
George W Bush figure who left a woman
who died at the bottom of a river and
then was excused with two months of
probation right and the two months
served was the time served rather than
serve a day in jail for any of this
imagine how quickly that movie would be
made by Hollywood it went for 50 years
without a Hollywood movie being made
about this but now that movie is out and
if you're a conservative and you care
about the culture and you care about
film you need to go see the movie
because you must support films that
actually tell the truth even if they're
50 years late go check it out I'm amazed
that it was made
it's really phenomenal and it does paint
a well-rounded I think nuanced picture
of Teddy Kennedy at the time and the and
the Kennedy family which was replete
with scumbags and Liars so go check that
out
Chappaquiddick this weekend ok so I have
a lot more to say about the US military
being used to guard the us-mexico border
but first you're gonna have to go over
to Daley water so for $9.99 a month you
get the rest of the daily wire
shows you get the rest of my show live
the rest of Clayton's show live the rest
of Michael Knowles's show live you get
all of those things and then you also
get to be part of the conversation so
our next episode of the conversation is
coming up next Tuesday April 10th 5:30
p.m. Eastern at 2:30 p.m. Pacific this
was my good friend Andrew Clavin and my
other good friend Alicia Kraus she hosts
it and you ask your questions and Andrew
answers them for a full hour it's free
for everybody to watch at youtube or or
at or at Facebook but only subscribers
can ask the questions so if you want to
ask a question subscribe log in to our
website at daily wire.com and head over
to the conversation page to watch the
live stream and after that just start
typing into the daily wired chat box and
I'll answer questions well drew well as
they come in for an entire hour once
again subscribe to get your questions
answered also subscribe because on
Friday we do our mailbag and then you
can get your questions answered by me
the greatest question answer question
answerer of the modern era you can ask a
question directly - mwah if you
subscribe right now get that annual
subscription instead of the monthly for
99 dollars a year it's cheaper and you
also get the Tumblr the leftist here's
how to call tumblr that so many louder
with crowd our subscribers are jealous
of so check that out over at daily wired
icon get the subscription it always
helps us make the show possible hire all
of our hirelings to do slave labor as
slave labor at nearest slave wages so
check that out please get the
subscription we appreciate it we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so President Trump wants to put national
guardsman on the border makes perfect
sense to me I do not see why this is a
big problem but there are two groups of
people who do have a big problem with
this people who are sort of the normal
Democrats and then the Radical Democrats
so we'll start with the normal Democrats
David Gorgon over on CNN has been a
longtime democratic political consultant
he's angry about this not because the
policy is bad but because he thinks
president Trump is too militaristic the
most disturbing part of the news though
to me today was this notion that he's
why he wants to snow send troops to the
border you know it's true that two past
presidents have a deployed National
Guard to the board yeah I was because
there were pressing needs there's no
pressing need here this is more of a
political move and it suggests that the
president recently sees the military as
a play toy that he can make political
points with first he wants to have this
big massive parade which to most people
to military look at and say oh why are
we really doing this in the country
shrugging his shoulders bees now got the
money yeah I wanted to take money out of
the military budget and pay for the wall
and now he wants to send troops to the
border there's no real reason why we
need to present troops to the border
okay this is ridiculous okay I'm sorry
this is just ridiculous George W Bush
sent a border deployment of the National
Guard known as operation jump started in
2006 it lasted for two full years the
operation sent more than 6,000 troops to
California Arizona New Mexico and Texas
to repair secondary border fence
according to CNN and construct nearly
1000 metal barriers and fly Border
Protection agents by helicopter to
intercept immigrants trying to enter
illegally and then another President did
this too does anyone remember I don't
remember remember all the way back to
2010 when Barack Obama did this hey
Barack Obama deployed National Guard
troops as part of a border protection
plan in 2010 they said up to 1200
National Guard troops would be in place
along the us-mexico border for up to a
year to assist US Customs and Border
Protection so Democrats are upset with
this because the guy who's doing its
name is Trump otherwise they wouldn't
care but the suggestion that Trump sees
the military as a plaything and that's
why he's doing this
Trump literally campaigned on
solidifying the border that's what he
campaigned on so there is no problem
here that's absurd
but there's a deeper problem and that is
you know I was asked yesterday by it by
somebody specifically about this issue
why are so many Democrats why are so
many folks on the radical
interested in open borders and I said
because there's a group of people who
really believe that America bears blood
guilt for all of the problems in the
rest of the world they look at America
they see America's rich America's
powerful but a lot of people all over
the world who are poor who are not
powerful lots of countries all over the
world where people are suffering that's
our fault because we're rich and
powerful in their view world politics is
a zero-sum game well just demonstrating
this tucker carlson
had on last night a fellow who calls
himself a border angel his name is reka
Enrique morones he is a person who
attempts to smuggle people across the
border he's a founder of the the caravan
of migrants that was headed to the US
via the us-mexico border from Central
and Latin America and here he is the
tucker carlson explaining why he thinks
that it's fine to smuggle people across
the border and in tucker yeah does a
good job with with both making the the
famed tucker carlson face as well as as
well as quizzing this guy in the united
states interfering in these countries
the demand for the drugs invading the
sovereign land like iraq or interfering
the civil wars or central america that
causes people to flee the u.s. Martians
are the reason you hate Americans what
you're saying very good actually
you're blaming America for legal
immigration into America
okay and that that is essentially what
he's saying Tucker knows a good job of
boiling it down there but this guy is
saying that America is responsible for
sins all over the world so America
should take in all of the refugees from
those sins so a couple of things that
are weird about that number one if you
really think America is such a terrible
place filled with such awful people why
do you why do people want to get in
right if a country victimized my country
and destroyed my country and made my
country a red state why would I want to
live in the country that just wrecked my
state why would I want to be a citizen
of the country that is apparently just a
predatory force around the globe that's
that's a weird logical gap maybe just
for the materialistic gain I suppose but
the other point here is that there is an
actual attempt by some members of the
radical left to castigate America for
our global sins again the idea being
that America is bad and America must be
punished too much of America's foreign
policy from the left has been based on
this when Barack Obama did his fabled
apology tour Oh
the Middle East in Europe after he was
elected this was the basic message
America has sinned in the world and we
are here to rectify those sins and if
that means that we have to curb our
economy with the Paris Accords cracking
down on American economic growth for the
sake of KY miracle environmental gain
then we will do it everything will be
fine because we deserve it we deserve it
it's our fault right and if it comes to
propping up the UN one of the most
useless in nefarious institutions in the
history of modern of modern politics if
we have to do that in order to slap
America itself we'll do that because
America is a guilty place filled with
guilty people and they have to pay now
this view of the left is a really
dangerous one and if you're wondering
why politics has become so polarized and
so so yelling and so screaming it's
because there's no way to have a
rational conversation with people who
legitimately believe that the United
States has to pay for its past sins and
that virtually everything counts as an
American sent some president Trump says
is gonna put people on the border I'm
all in on that I think that's a
perfectly rational thing to do and I
also think that the illegal immigration
crisis is not all that hard to solve
it's just that there are a bunch of
people on the Left particularly who
don't want that crisis solved they want
more illegal immigration because they
think that America ought to pay on a
moral level that's on the radical left
it's not every Democrat you know there
are many other Democrats who don't want
to solve the illegal immigration
situation because they believe that
they're going to be able to get
additional Democratic voters as people
are made citizens or they believe that
for example a bunch of people are going
to vote Democrat if they see nasty
pictures of Republicans pushing for
deportations it's a political football
but again this core group of leftists
who believe that America is a bad a bad
force in the world and therefore we must
be punished by taking in all sorts of
refugees and immigrants that's that's
dangerous stuff and there's no way that
the United States can can survive with
that sort of perspective becoming more
and more common okay and just as so now
I want to talk about something that
really weird that happened yesterday
this is a weird thing that happened
yesterday to me so I have become
friendly with a student at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas high school whose name
is Kyle Kashyap he first started
becoming prominent when he was speaking
out in favor of gun rights even though
he was a witness to what happened at the
Parkland element at the Parkland High
School and
entire left basically ignored him and so
I pointed out to the media that they
should stop ignoring survivors who
disagreed with them and so he started
getting booked a little bit more and one
of the things that has happened in the
past couple of days is that there are a
bunch of people on the Left who have
attacked him and the reason this is
relevant is because of course there was
this massive boycott launched against
Laura Ingraham by the left suggesting
that she'd been mean to another parkland
survivor named David Hogg David Hogg of
course had been the kid who'd gone on TV
and suggested that everyone who
disagreed with him was basically a
murderer with blood on their hands
taking NR a blood money and Laura
Ingraham said that he was whining about
his college admissions and ill-advised
comment and then there was a boycott
against her well Kyle was attacked in
much more nefarious fashion by the left
and no one seems to be commenting on
this other than to say that the guy who
did it is kind of crazy so the guy who
did it
is a guy named Kurt - Wald Kurt
Eisenwald on his bio on his bio on
Twitter five days ago it said he was an
MSNBC contributor and a vanity fair-- a
contributing editor right that's what it
said on his on his biography well a few
days ago he ripped into Kyle on Twitter
I pointed this out and MSNBC started
losing sponsors and so MSNBC came out
and said well actually we would not
hired him for since February 24 since
February he hasn't been able to to
really do anything since February hasn't
been with MSNBC so first court had to
had to remove the MSNBC contributor part
of his Twitter profile so suddenly it
just said Kurt I can Wald Vanity Fair
contributing editor New York Times
best-selling author
okay then yesterday Kurt sent me this
wild email this wild wild email and
here's what its heads had been I'm
working on an article about you and your
relationship with Kyle cash of the kid
from parkland
I'm not gonna be using his name for
reasons that will become apparent a few
items one he's been actively working to
trick journalists he believes work for
non Fox television networks into taking
any action in something in which his
Twitter account was linked to he's been
cordoning with some of the trolls
involved with these people three he in
fact coordinated with the other guy with
the podcast who was demanding my respect
he is the same attack on me as the other
guy which was unprovoked
he used this garbage pushed by
conservative media and leftist that I am
a fan of tentacle porn and that's that's
what he actually wrote because about a
year ago it turned out that Kurt I can
Wald
tweeted out a link accidental
- tentacle porn and I think that was the
story and and/or he tweeted out a
picture of himself in the background of
his computer was a picture of tentacle
porn something like that and then he
said that he was just using it for
research purposes or he wanted to show
his kids he was his kids had said
something about tentacle porn didn't
believe that it was real so he went
looking for it in any case this became a
point of humor against current I can
walled and this email that he sent to me
about Kyle goes on and on and on and on
I mean it is a long long email and the
best part of it was where he says this
so remember all of this started with
Kurt I can Wald saying that the boycott
against Laura Ingraham was justified
because Laura Ingraham had been mean to
a park land survivor
Kyle cash-flow at i/o cashew is a park
land survivor here is what Kurt I can
well wrote in this email to me that he
sent to me this crazy email quote I
engaged in ADM conversation with Kyle
which was quite disturbing I consulted a
friend of mine who is a psychiatrist a
political conservative since that seems
so important to you and based on what he
read the psychiatrist said the following
one Kyle is in desperate need of
psychiatric help or support the
psychiatrist did not have enough
information to assess if the issues he
saw in the conversation where the
consequence of the shooting being
psychologically unprepared for being
thrust into the conservative media as a
go-to kid or if there's an underlying
pathology that preceded these events -
Kyle is obsessed with you
in fact our DM conversation with you
which involves a lot of irrational rage
seems to have been sparked by my asking
you to debate and then he goes on and
finally the very end of this email he
asks a series of questions suggesting
that I am running Kyle that I am the
nefarious for it the Kyle doesn't have
his own opinions he wasn't conservative
before he met me that Kyle has been
getting his cues from me now listen I've
openly said on the program that I talked
with Kyle feel like there's no secret
about this I think Kyle is a good kid I
think he's trying to do the right thing
and I think he deserves support in the
same way that I'm sure that David hog
talks with a bunch of folks on the Left
including Media Matters there's nothing
wrong with that but the best part of
this email is where Kurt says at the
very end of it don't forward this email
to Kyle he does not need to know what a
psychiatrist is saying about him you
have heard him enough so this guy who
purported to be a Vanity Fair
contributing editor he sends me an email
accusing Kyle Kash of a parkland
survivor of being psychologically
deficient right to having a psychiatric
problem
and then says at the end of the email
that I am harming him and I shouldn't
afford the email so naturally I did what
any rational person would do when you
receive a crazy email like this I
immediately posted it on Twitter the
entire text of it and Vanity Fair
responded by sending out a notice that
Kurt I can wall no longer works for
Vanity Fair that he hasn't worked for
Vanity Fair for several years so Kurt's
Twitter biography shrunk yet again and
now he was no longer a nemesis MSNBC
contributor or a Vanity Fair
contributing editor he he actually
emailed I believe his brian Stelter CNN
claiming that no he was still a Vanity
Fair contributing editor and vaneeta was
like that no you're not and you haven't
written for us since 2014 so all of this
is to say listen I don't want to pick on
a guy when he's down
pick a guy when he's down but all of
this is to say that there are people on
the Left who do attack parkland
survivors and the blowback on them does
not extend to their to their venues it
doesn't really extend to their outlets
it's been largely ignored right John
Walsh as we played yes as we use and
played yesterday said some nasty things
about Kyle cash there's been no boycott
effort against CNN when the left wants
to boycott something they're doing it
for political purposes the right usually
is better than that and usually doesn't
engage in these kind of boycotts unless
it is a reverse boycott like they're
boycotting chick-fil-a and we say okay
we'll all go shop at chick-fil-a just to
show that we're not going to allow you
to boycott institutions we like out of
business but it's amazing what the same
left that says you can't target a
parklands shooter it can't target rather
a parkland survivor will say that if
it's a power Clin survivor we don't like
that we will actually go have them
psychologically evaluated without their
knowledge and then say that you should
not tell the person that that happened
it's an amazing thing and frankly I
think the kyle has a very solid legal
case for defamation against Curt so
we'll see how all of that goes but
things certainly are crazy okay time for
a couple of things I like and then a
couple of things that I hate so things
that I like since it is the middle of
Passover I would be remiss if I did not
play some music from The Prince of Egypt
I remember when I first saw this movie
as an Orthodox Jew I found a couple of
things a little irritating about it
because it's not exactly biblically
accurate in a couple of ways so for
example they use the trope that is used
I believe in the original Ten
Commandments as well that the the king
of Egypt is the same age as Moses right
that Pharaoh is the same age as Moses
they're actually brothers their adopted
brothers
not that Pharaoh was older the there's
not a lot of evidence in the Bible that
Pharaoh was in fact Moses his adopted
brother as opposed to Moses adoptive
father but in any case the movie itself
is worth watching it is quite good it
was I believe the first DreamWorks major
animation film if I'm not mistaken and
the music and Stephen Schwartz the same
guy who did wicked and the rest of music
in the film is done by Hans Zimmer who
of course has gone on to have an
enormous career doing things like
Christopher Nolan's Batman movies and
interstellar right here is the first
number in the in the musical deliver us
which is the best number in the whole
show
[Music]
[Applause]
all righty so go check it out it's
really a great number and the Prince of
Egypt is well worth watching okay time
for a very quick thing that I hate so
Steven Spielberg says it is time for a
woman to play Indiana Jones oh say
here's what he said he said he knew he
would risk phantom fury by casting an
actress in the role made famous by
Harrison Ford but believes it his time
the Explorer took a different form he
make the expenditure owns like a dog or
something I guess I mean it any
different form will work apparently an
exclusive interview Spielberg nodded
when asked if this new look Jones could
be female and added we'd have to change
the name from Jones to Joan and there
would be nothing wrong with that he's
been a vocal champion of The Times up
campaign for gender equality in the
movie industry and of course he was
married to the actress Kate Capshaw
since 1991 he met her in 1984 she
starred in Indiana Jones in the Temple
of Doom she's an awful actress by the
way I mean that in in Temple do my
goodness whoa that's a stinker but in
any case he says my mom was strong she
had a voice she had a very strong
opinion actually I knew his mom and she
used to run a kosher restaurant on Pico
Boulevard called milk and honey which is
quite good but he says that he thinks
this will be Harrison Jones Harrison
Ford's last Indiana Jones movie would
have to be because Harrison Ford is
pushing 80 at this point he's really
getting up there it's Indiana Jones and
the and the kingdom of the actual skull
is where we are at this point but when
you have Steven Spielberg's saying that
we're gonna take iconic male characters
and then shift them to female I've said
this before I find it really stupid one
of the things that's great about film
one things that's great about art is
that specificity is universality so the
more specific the character is the
better the art is because in specific we
see what we have in common with other
people when you draw a person really
well what you see is what I have in
common with that person and that's
universal if you draw people broadly so
broadly that you can legitimately just
take a woman and put in a man's role
then it's not good it's not like I think
this is the reason that the movie atomic
blonde didn't do well at the box office
it was because basically Charlize Theron
is playing a male role but she's just a
woman and I guess this is for female
equality or somesuch but it's okay to
have a female action star who's a woman
right I mean Ridley Scott did it with
aliens with Sigourney Weaver and it
works fine because guess what Sigourney
Weaver plays a woman and she plays a
woman like a woman and she's very
aggressive woman
film obviously but she plays it like a
woman and you couldn't put a man in that
role and have them read the same lines
the whole point of Indiana Jones Indiana
Jones is a dude he's a dudes dude and
this is the same sort of conversation
we've had about a female James Bond
there should not be a female James Bond
James Bond is a character with a
specific personality that is male in
orientation and the same thing is true
with regard to with regard to Indiana
Jones don't take iconic characters and
just make them women build a new
character
if field wants to build a new female
character go for it it's all you but
it's irritating to suggest that women
and men are exactly the same and
therefore you can just pop a woman in a
man's role and it's totally fine no
problem whatsoever
okay we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest updates I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018